what else we had the uh we had the
Roseanne uh our Roseanne episode got
taken down do a little bit of business
with you guys here
um our Roseanne episode got taken down
uh and we got strikes on YouTube uh a
strike
on YouTube
and we couldn't post for a week those
were the rules
um and at first I was really shocked you
know I believe that I believe that what
Roseanne said was satire
right I believe that wholeheartedly I
believe that she is a comedian I know
she's a comedian we're having a
certificate we're having a conversation
she was being satirical to me very
evident
um
now YouTube has their own policies they
have hate speech policies and that's
what we got uh our strike for was hate
speech
um and I think I was I was kind of
offended by that
you know I thought I didn't think that
that was
um
I didn't think that it was fair
and I think the toughest part was
there's no communication you don't get
to communicate with YouTube really about
it
right they kind of this ruling comes
from like a place you can't or people
you can't communicate with or access and
then
um that's how they do it right
and now I understand they have their
policies and they have to do their best
to uphold their policies right and I'm
thankful to YouTube I'm very grateful
that it exists
right because I have a place to speak
from
um
you know I have a platform uh from which
to talk and and a place to host a show
like I'm very grateful for that
truly am
but yeah I think the tough part was just
that it felt like there was no
communication about it it was just like
this is what it is
and
and I understand that's their policies
but I think there was
um there should be I feel like you
should have some conversation about it
because they call
for YouTube they call you like Partners
right you're like we're partners
you know
because I'm not an employee of YouTube
but I'm a partner that's what they they
call it you know that you're a partner
YouTube Partner
and so
yeah I just felt like if I'm a partner
then let's at least have a discussion
with me about what's going on
um
so you can hear what I'm you can hear
what I'm thinking and what I'm feeling
you know so I think that was the
toughest part I just felt like it was
kind of uh
uh I felt like there was no chance for
me to
speak
or share what I was thinking or feeling
and maybe that's just how it is you know
that's business
um you know I also have to take into
account that I want to be able to have a
show I want to be able to connect with
people
and um
and just times are different
you know people could say well you can
still have your voice even if you lose a
Channel or you're
social media gets taken down you still
have your own voice
which is true
but times have changed you know it's
like
um it's not just a soap box in your
neighborhood anymore in your tribe you
know your people are communicating with
a lot more people at once
and on bigger levels
um or different levels
um but when you communicate something
out in social media on YouTube it's
accessible to more people so it's not
like you're just standing on your
soapbox
you know in a town hall or something
um
so it's really like YouTube has kind of
become like paper like they're the paper
you know all these social media
platforms they're the paper now
and it's almost sometimes it feels like
well the paper
gets to determine what's written on it
whereas it used to feel more like hey
you can write what you want on this
paper
and deal with
people's Co and deal with consequences
or interpretations of it
but now as soon as it feels like well if
you
put something on this paper
the paper
is now determining what you're even
allowed to it's like as if a piece of
paper you're writing stuff on it and the
paper was able to edit as you're writing
so I don't know if that makes any sense
but
it's just you know it's just an
interesting time
now what was really crazy was that
when the episode got taken down I
believe that uh it should be able to
live somewhere right I believe that it
was a great episode I was really
grateful to
um be be able to talk with
you know a real Matrix matriarch yeah a
real matriarch of Comedy
you know she is
I mean
she there's nobody like Roseanne
you know and I know she's had a lot of
like things that have come at her over
the years a lot of
um you know she always makes controversy
she always does
um sometimes it seems like it's too much
for sure
uh other times it seems like
what you would expect out of a comedian
out of a
an instigator
you know it's kind of what you would
expect
um because that's what that's what
challenges comedians in the first place
like oh I can say this I can't say this
how do I
you know how do I Mill around this area
of taboo
right whatever the taboo is
um
but then so then I put the episode on to
Twitter
because they allow longer form episodes
now or longer video on there and then
Elon Musk
the freaking alien
liaison you know
he
he shared it
and so that went
I mean that was unbelievable that you
know just the fact that he did it you
know
um now and whatever you think about Elon
you know or whatever you you know that's
not it that that isn't that's not what
I'm thinking about I'm just thinking how
fat he was like a man who's like an
influential man
and he's sharing
you know me and Roseanne and I having a
conversation so
it was just pretty fascinating uh the
whole experience is kind of fascinating
you know I think I was bummed out
because I feel like I've done a lot of
like neat work on YouTube and I'll try
and show up every week for the channel
and
um
yeah so I think that's what that's what
it was like if we're Partners have a
discussion at least someone speak to me
um
but that's uh
that's there it's their it's their
platform
and those are that's how that's their
rules
and you know a lot of times we have to
play Within
um
the rules you know if I walk onto a
basketball court I I know
the rules you know and
that's the rules so hope you enjoyed
that video and you can watch another and
you can watch this one you can watch
this one different options different
choices some guy just brings you one
option not this guy two options watch
one this one or this one